[Music]
what's the deal with everything peanuts
peanuts what do you see that's different
about that Austin scene what do you
think with Joe's Club being built do you
think it can get to that place where it
is the third biggest city for comedy I
think it'll be number one
I really really truly believe that I
mean I already see it I see the amount
of tickets that we sell casually like
it's nothing like people are just dying
for it and waiting for it and people are
flying into Austin now when they used to
fly into LA and New York to have a
comedy weekend Joe Rogan Tom segora Tony
Hinchcliffe Tim Dylan Ron White David
Lucas and Duncan Trussell are some of
the biggest names in comedy who've
recently made the move to Austin Texas
but there might be an even larger group
of comedians headed there soon it's no
secret the City of Austin has quickly
transformed into one of the country's
main comedy hubs since Joe Rogan made
the move back in 2020 with over eight
established comedy clubs multiple
theaters and even more satellite rooms
it's clear why comedians have begun to
flock towards Texas you'll move here
thinking about it I thought about it I
thought about it more today and I
thought about it yesterday yeah
what percentage you think you're
thinking about it I thought 30 which was
surprising I didn't think I would think
about it that much 30 I'll say this a
zillowed new zealog really last night
where are you looking found it's pretty
pricey I found that even Theo Von one of
the biggest names in comedy period has
been debating joining the Austin
movement ever since last November
similar to Joe Rogan Theo left La back
in 2020 but opted to move to Nashville
at the time A lot has changed since then
and now it seems like theovan's chances
to move to Texas have gone from 30 up to
100 with Joe Rogan confirming the news a
few weeks back a lot of people moved
away Theo moved to Nashville Theo Vaughn
but was there a comedy scene there a
little bit a little bit you know but
like there's Nate bargatzi who's
fantastic he's there but Theo's gonna
move here now so it's like he's excited
about it too there's so many people that
have moved here it's crazy yeah any
given night we'll have like [__] eight
eight Comics up at the Vulcan it's wild
Caleb pressy thank you this is probably
the last time you'll ever be in
Nashville unless we come back to fight
this busting with the boys dudes all
right let's that's you dude that's your
journey those are my friends are they
what
I love those guys it's over they had
beef huh you told me they had beef y'all
got beef man yeah you're right and if
for whatever reason Theo Von moving to
Texas isn't enough to make Austin the
comedy Capital there's also plenty of
speculation that Shane Gillis could be
on his way to town next we might have to
break out the New York Matrix yeah
that'd be tight it could be time dude
could be
we'll see yeah it could be we'll see
Trail stay tuned stay tuned
gotcha going to Alaska we're moving to
Alaska it'll be awesome it's the new
comedy Hub Alaska Juno
just get ripped apart by bears maybe
it's only because he filmed this special
there back in 2021 but something about
Shane Gillis moving in Texas just feels
right he's already down there almost
once a month doing shows filming protect
our parks and being a guest on kill Tony
plus Shane Gillis has a ton of fans in
common with the comedians who already
live there like Joe Rogan Tom Segura and
Tim Dillon we get Ari Shane and Norman
there for I know they love it four days
a month and Rogan's bringing good Comics
down to be on his show yep I mean that's
what made me think about it was like I
would like to go for a month and just
have an experience of it what does it
really feel like to be there go out get
you a sandwich get you a coffee get you
a you know you know find a wife or
something or see it and you know and do
comedy at night while you're trying to
do that you know and and have a you know
like a lifestyle of it people are coming
to visit those New Yorkers or that are
real joke Gunslingers we just had a tell
on the show on Monday he just did a
whole weekend in Austin and he's looking
at it with a twinkle in his eye like
wait what are you guys doing here this
does you guys do this every Monday and
then you do okay like and to any
comedian you know Comedy Store or style
you know or comedy seller style they
come to Austin and they're looking at it
with like okay so maybe I'll spend like
a week out of every month here no
although it may feel like literally
every single comedian has either brought
up moving to Austin or has at least
considered making the jump there's still
quite a few very talented comedians who
have made it known publicly they are not
moving to Texas including Bobby Lee
Andrew Santino Mark Norman and Chris
DiStefano I truly feel like I'm a guy
that I think as I've gotten you know
older a little bit all I want is to have
a career that keeps me in New York like
if you said hey you're not going on the
road anymore but you'll be able to
sustain your way of life and not leave
New York I would be happy with that tell
my father was my father did not leave
you ready for this my father did not
leave this state of New York or New
Jersey till he was 71 years old that was
the first time he left you land in New
York and you're like oh good to be home
[__] I can't get an Uber or the Uber's
800 or I got shanked on the [__] air
train you know there's always something
with this city it just [__] you right
in the ass it finds a way so it is great
it is awesome it is culturally diverse
and we got every kind of music and food
and the city is beautiful but it is Hell
in a lot of ways it's not natural way to
live the tiny Apartments the freezing
cold the trash piling up the rats you
know there's a lot of downfall enjoy it
while you're here it is a great I I I'm
gonna raise kids here so you're here to
stay I'm here yeah do you ever go to La
and feel like oh I could or would live
here I love LA but I love to visit and
I'd say the same with Austin Austin is
beautiful it's great the weather is
amazing but
I feel like La I
I see through it within like a week I'm
like all right I'm out I got it I'm
going back to a real City rebuilding the
Universe I mean it's just got it's it
has to be somewhere it's it's cool if
that place becomes an epicenter of
Comedy I know so many people moving
there yeah I can't no
we just bought this house and I I have
almost no money so at this point I can't
do it I just gotta like you know the
only way is if
you know
no I yeah I'd be so hard it'd be so hard
to do also you know I've got the podcast
with noodles and like what am I gonna do
with that yeah do you know what I mean
like he's not he can't leave here dude
it would be awesome if you move there
and just started it with just any Korean
guy random Korean guy yeah uh yeah no
we're we can't go anywhere we'll be
probably and Bert's gonna stay are you
gonna stay in La for a while yeah for
what whatever forever I'm in La guy for
are you I love la I love La too those
[__] idiots that moved to Texas
those [__] morons some of them are
coming back Tim Dillon I saw him the
other night he's like I'm moving back
October 1st it's like no [__] yeah
Southern on the joy Diaz podcast yeah
they're gonna come back but yeah there's
nothing out there I mean it's gonna be
fun for three years yeah LA's the best
like Bobby Lee mentioned in the previous
clip Tim Dylan was one of the very first
comedians to follow Joe to Texas but
shortly after the move started trashing
Austin on his podcast and splitting his
time between Austin and la and there'll
be a photo of where Mommy got shot not
on Sixth Street and that is all this
[__] City will ever be burned
these rants by Tim have not only been
really funny but have also seemed very
realistic that is until this clip
surfaced of Tony Hinchcliffe revealing
Tim Dillon's real reasoning for not
fully committing to Austin here's my
other Theory but is there enough
comedians will there be enough this
that's my question because there are
guys like Tim Dillman have gone there
and left yeah he's there Tim's there
he's just waiting for Joe's Club to be
full-time Tim has more property in
Austin than anybody he talks a lot of
[__] but he's like buying it up really
oh yeah dude he gets it hmm Tim's out
here killing it and Segura and Christina
and me and Joe and Ron White and a whole
bunch of the the youth another
interesting thing that's also important
to consider is how many young new Comics
are moving to Austin obviously any City
with Joe Rogan Shane Gillis Tom segora
and theovan will be considered a top
tier comedy scene but in order to
maintain that level it's essential to
have a strong class of developing
comedians coming up ready to take the
reins which has already been the model
in New York City for some time now
giving it one of the best comedy
reputations in the world if you're a
young comic are you going to come to New
York
and toil away in obscurity for four
years
in destitute poverty do you come here
and then compete with the best comics in
the world
for stage time which is going to be very
difficult
or do you go to a new city where the
best Comics would haven't moved there
yet and the new ones haven't developed
into it yet their stage time and money
and seven clubs without the same level
of competition so if you're a brand new
comic do you go there for four years
before you come to New York right do you
go there for four or five years before
you go to La and try to be you know in
sitcoms or whatever the [__] you want to
do do you learn and develop your craft
in this place
it to me I'm like wow that is a very
intriguing possibility
and the world is wrld
[Music]